welcome to the man of Recaps this is the
Mandalorian season 3 The Mandalorian is
back din jarin with his little baby Yoda
friend grogu remember season two ended
with grogu going to train to be a Jedi
with Luke Skywalker but in the book of
Boba Fett long story short grogu decided
he wanted to be a Mandalorian instead
with his papa Mando but when saying
goodbye mendover moved his helmet
showing Pedro Pascal's beautiful face
which is against the Creed he's now an
apostate he can only be redeemed in the
sacred Living Waters on the planet of
Mandalore which is apparently totally
inaccessible so Mando goes to check it
out and indeed it was completely
destroyed by the Empire but it's not
actually Radioactive It's still a
dangerous place though Mando's
immediately captured by this General
Grievous Droid looking guy so it's up to
grogu to get help from his Mandalorian
Auntie bogutan she busts in to rescue
him during the fight she grabs the
darksaber that he dropped and oh takes
out this Droid with it but remember the
dark saber has to be won in combat so it
still belongs to Mando for now so she
takes ninja into the Living Waters but
she neglects to mention how deep it is
whoa he falls down she Dives in to
rescue him again and down here she find
something very unexpected an absolutely
massive monster thing this is the
legendary mythosar whose skull is the
Mandalorian logo but they're not
supposed to actually exist so bocatan
keeps this to herself for now they go
back to bokutan's Castle but the
Imperial Remnant force is founded first
and blew it up so they go to Mando's
place instead now that Mando took his
magic bath congrats man you're redeemed
but Boca tan went in the waters also and
she hasn't taken her helmet off since so
technically she's redeemed too she's
like yeah I mean I'm homeless now I may
as well join this cult and also joining
the cult is baby Yoda yeah he's not a
baby anymore he's old enough to fight
and with his new Jedi jump training from
Luke Skywalker yeah he's gonna be a
beast he earns his first new armor piece
and oh my God he's so stupid cute
meanwhile back on Navarro the planet the
show started on which was a lawless
Frontier Town but now under the
leadership of high magistrates grief
karga it's become a nice happy place but
some of the pirates that used to hang
out here didn't get the memo Mando's got
to tell him what's what and Captain
seaweed Davey Jones doesn't like that he
tries to take over the city they ask for
help from the new Republic but Navarro
didn't join the new Republic so it's not
their problem so Amanda's friend Captain
Carson tiva lets him know Navarro's in
trouble so Mandalorian reinforcements
fly in oh it's an epic Action episode
pew pew pew flying around and so the
mandalorians who once lived in the
sewers here are now Heroes of the planet
and gifted a bunch of land but their
leader the armorer has bigger plans now
that she knows Mandalore is not
radioactive and bocatan told her she saw
a mythosar which is a sign she gives
Boca 10 permission to remove her helmet
so she can go back to the other
Mandalorian Clans unite them all and
retake their Homeworld on the way per
usual they're roped into a side quest
with Jack Black and lizzo it's an
episode of CSI Star Wars where
Christopher Lloyd is the bad guy whose
account Dooku sympathizer then they find
the other mandalorians bokeh damn
challenges to be their leader again but
it's still that same old problem they
won't follow her without the darksaber
but now tinjan points out that he was
disarmed and book tan picked it up and
killed the guy who disarmed him so if
you go by Harry Potter Elder Wand rules
technically Boca tan is now the rightful
owner of the darksaber so all our
mandalorians united in purpose fly off
to Mandalore to take their Planet back
but there's no one to take it back from
the planets abandoned or is it because
they're ambushed by a bunch of flying
jetpack Stormtroopers they lead him into
a trap where dinjarin is captured and
who is this epic black suit Mandalorian
flying in you know it that's moth Gideon
yeah at the end of season two he was
going off to jail in the new Republic
but of course he escaped turns out these
Imperial remnants are much stronger and
more organized than we thought they call
themselves The Shadow Council and this
ties into the Star Wars sequel Trilogy
as this will be the beginnings of the
first order most of them are awaiting
the return of their leader Grand Admiral
thrawn yeah a big character from Star
Wars Rebels but muff Gideon's like yo
he'll show up in the Ahsoka show I'm the
main villain of this one over the series
we've kind of guessed that Gideon's
master plan is making clones of himself
with the baby Yoda Force Powers a
technology that theoretically will lead
to the creation of supreme leader snoke
there's a whole episode devoted to the
scientist who was working on that
project but he's not a bad guy he was
pardoned under the new Republic's
amnesty program but he makes friends
with this other ex-imperial who long
story shorts tricks him into violating
his whole and secretly she is still
loyal to the Empire so she turns his
brainwashing thing all the way up and
watch out for that so now after getting
his butt kicked by mandalorians two
seasons in a row he's decided to make
his own best car steel armor and turns
out the abandoned Mandalore was a
perfect secret base he's got a whole
Fleet here so as the mandalorians escape
the big one pause vizla stays behind for
an epic Last Stand oh denjarin was
captured he's fighting to break free and
let's go back for a second earlier
Amanda wanted to rebuild his Droid
friend ig11 who saved them in season one
without a new memory core though it's
not possible but it is possible to turn
him into a walking mech suit for baby
Yoda his papa Mando's like I don't think
so but baby Yoda loves it oh he's
walking around got a yes or no voice
button he can get into so much more
trouble so now yes he busts in there to
save his papa Mando and they go to hunt
down moff Gideon they find his Force
Power clones which are almost ready oh
absolutely not to destroy all those then
they find the man himself and it's time
for their epic rematch meanwhile the
other mandalorians have regrouped and
now they're all flying in Boca tan whips
out the dark saber and it's an epic jet
pack flying battle oh yeah then book 10
comes down for her epic rematch with
Gideon oh yeah she's got the darksaber
but his new super suit grabs her hand
and breaks it oh darksaber is destroyed
so as things look Bleak they gotta take
this whole base out by crashing their
big ship into it our main characters
keep him down here so boom MAF Gideon
incinerated and our crew's okay because
baby Hoda with the force force field he
protected them and saves the day and so
we've made it to the mandalorians have
retaken Mandalore now it's time for
grogu to level up in this cult from
foundling to Apprentice but for that he
needs parental permission and so they
make it official din jarin adopts him
he's now din grogu but they're not
sticking around here part of being an
apprentice you have to go off on a
journey so Mando goes to his new
Republic friend hey you guys have your
hands full out here we're available as
freelance bounty hunters they make
Navarro their home base where they found
a new IG memory unit so IG 11's back as
the Marshal of Navarro and so after 3
seasons of being on the Run fighting to
survive Mando and baby Yoda finally
settle down and get to live happily ever
after except of course you know for a
potentially infinite number of awesome
new adventures and that's where the
Mandalorian season 3 comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]